[Musique]
la fin du blocage donc dans le port de
marseille les thoniers ont levé ce matin
leur barrage à l'entrée du port de
commerce à l'aube et il avait à nouveau
encerclée le rainbow warrior le narb le
navire de greenpeace escorté par un
remorqueur de la préfecture maritime a
finalement levé l'ancré en direction du
large l'association écologiste renonce
donc à marseille a mené sa campagne
d'information sur la pêche au thon rouge
en méditerranée le film des événements
avec yvon martinet et michel commun le
rainbow warrior lève l'anc fin des
hostilités
deezer le trois-mâts keep la rade de
marseille tractée par l'abeille flandre
le remorqueur de la marine nationale
épilogue d'une matinée mouvementée
7 heures du matin autour du rainbow
warrior la bataille navale peut
commencer les marins pêcheurs lancent
leur zodiac sur ceux de greenpeace sur
place la gendarmerie maritime
n'intervient pas vous n'allez rien faire
monsieur contre les pratiques illégales
ces manoeuvres extrêmement dangereuse
c'est complètement fou c'est que ils
nous balancent des boullereaux que la
gendarmerie est là à 100 mev et qu'elle
ne fait absolument rien alors qu'elle
était parfaitement prévu prévenu que les
thoniers senneurs allait faire cette
action les militants de greenpeace sont
à bout une heure plus tôt le rainbow
warrior est pris d'assaut un thonier sur
chaque flanc deux autres devant et
derrière le trois-mâts les pêcheurs
monter à l'abordage samar au rainbow
warrior les écologistes eux résistent
comme ils peuvent s'accroche au
bastingage peine perdue contre le
remorquer le rainbow warrior
nécessaire de toutes sortes qui quittera
bel marseille
baroud d'honneur les marins touche au
but le préfet veut s'entretenir avec
mourad kahoul leur porte parole deezer a
eu l'accord des deux parties
d'une table
le bateau devait spears sait car tous
genres manquer vous n'avez pas
déterminer si les pêcheurs s'écarte du
bateau ce qui est en train de se faire
confirmer
l'ordre tous les bateaux de s'écarter lp
maintenant 1000 sécurité pour la
remorque se faire correctement
aussitôt les pêcheurs tienne parole et
libère le port
on est désolé pour cotonou pour les
marseillais pour les entreprises et pour
notre gouvernement d'avoir créé ces
soucis-là mais il était indispensable
pour nous de faire valoir les besoins de
notre profession greenpeace expulsé ça
vaut pourtant une demi-victoire le
conflit aura permis une large
médiatisation de leurs actions et
revendications
il faut passer à une autre étape nous
avons demandé au ministre des pêches
d'organiser très rapidement la
concertation très professionnelle mais
scientifiques et les associations
il faut résoudre le problème du thon
rouge en méditerranée
le rainbow warrior devrait dès demain
gagné carthagène et y poursuivre sa
campagne d'information
[Musique]